do you find it
um a gift and a curse
being a social like obviously
with being a part of dipset and the lore
in the history there's always
uh a built-in fan base for that like
it's almost like
you know fan base buys like as soon as
like you
like somebody finds out your dip set
like right now with tde
so if tde signs somebody they got crazy
fans that are just gonna [ __ ] with that
artist no matter what
is that a gift and a curse to kind of
like always carry the dip set
like which you like like is it it's a
gift and a curse because it's like
sometimes a person might not know how to
answer a certain question
at a certain moment you know what i'm
saying because it's a bunch of us you
know what i'm saying plus
that name is attached so anywhere i go
whether i do an interview next week
them questions is going to come up you
know what i'm saying so but i don't
think
it's a it's a curse at all you know what
i mean i don't think it's a curse
um because i helped build that you know
what i'm saying so i don't think it's a
curse